melissa is with us in Oklahoma hi Alyssa
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi guys
okay so my this is my third time calling
we're working the baby steps and I
always have a question but we're on baby
steps you still and we paid like 19 K
since November when we first started and
my husband and I have a disagreement
going on he is concerned with our credit
score going down don't yell at me I this
is his this is his question he's
concerned with his credit score going
down because we're paying off everything
not using credit cards and so what
actually his chaplain told him he's in
the using the army and he said that he
suggests putting gas on the credit card
every month tooth to pay it off right
away
cause his chaplains a millionaire I do
not agree what do I sell my husband he's
you're not Hebrew
why don't ask my car mechanic for
financial advice I don't last my
financial advisor for for spiritual
advice totally so I don't know where the
chaplain came into play here maybe he's
leading FPU classes and I need to stop
him from doing that but other than that
this chaplain is completely irrelevant
here's the thing ask your husband okay
the only reason you need a credit score
there's only one reason to go into that
yeah so why you need a credit score
gnosis debt think I'm good to you no no
I mean I'm you I'm not picking on you
you told me four times it wasn't you it
was him I got it okay but I'm telling
you this is what I would say to her why
is it you need a credit score cuz you
wanna go back in debt I thought we had
an agreement on this I thought we
weren't going into debt again right all
right I thought we were through with we
wonder if we want to keep debt back
there in the back you know keep debt
like a you know the the child were
ashamed of when we lock it in the back
closet or something and only let it out
on Easter I mean what is this is it a
pet
Elisa's is he concerned about the
mortgage no so we're gonna be what with
the military like I said it's the only
concern is to announces where I didn't
know how to answer
I know it's mortgages you could do the
manual underwriting and there's better
information I was having a hard time
finding the answer for renting because
we will be moving in about a year and a
half and so that's his concern is so how
do we what do we do when it's time to
rent again if we don't want you to go to
Anthony's YouTube page and pull up the
video of Anthony calling apartment
complex after apartment complex after
apartment complex and what did you say
Anthony and what did they say and I was
just being awesome hey I don't have a
credit score do you are allow would you
allow me to rent and they said yes now
there were some extra things that came
with a day one of them said hey we will
require an extra deposit and that's fine
you know but most of them didn't even
say that yeah mostly did you even get
one that so they wouldn't rent no and I
call it in okay so you just help yeah
you now there will be some out there I'm
not gonna mislead you there will be some
that will probably say no but you didn't
even though I didn't file I wish you'd
have found just one so you could ragdoll
I so would but I mean just just do the
research at least I just just call
around tell them with your situation
tell them we don't have a credit score
but be honest right now you're good
you're in a good place
oh by the way I work for an employer
that really can't lay me off there you
go you know I mean it's not like you're
not gonna get your check you're in the
military right yeah yeah pull it up on
YouTube Anthony O'Neil it's a YouTube
channel and it's a great video it's only
about five minutes long six minutes long
just and type in can I rent an apartment
with no credit score and it'll bring it
right up and it's it's really kind of
humorous because all these people have
said for years well you can't so here's
the thing
you just have to decide what your
provider is yes and I learned a long
time ago if I want to build wealth my
provider has to be God and my own
abilities and my hustle and my grind
that's my provider it's not a bank and
it's not the government
said no one ever I became wealthy
because of the government yeah said no
one ever
I borrowed all I could borrow my whole
life and ended up with anything except
broke yeah that's it I mean it's just it
doesn't work so you've just got to
decide which game you're gonna play the
game that works or the game that doesn't
yeah you've been in this game for 25
years say if I got to ask you a question
I see this Instagram post going on I got
part about 100 people who tagged me on
it they said an 800 credit score is
stronger than $100,000 cash for what
purpose I don't know it is everyone's
saying yep that's true and I'm sitting
like no that's not true well it would be
true if you won't borrow money there you
go if you want to borrow if you want to
borrow a hundred thousand dollars
hundred thousand dollars cash off you
can do that instantly you could pledge
the hundred that's collateral yeah and
you might be able to borrow a hundred
thousand dollars not on the house I'm
just saying yeah like a line of credit
right just a personal line of credit for
a hundred grand I doubt you could do
that with an 800 credit score if you're
if you're how if your household income
was fifty grand
yeah so I don't think you could borrow a
hundred grand yeah unsecured but you
could well it wouldn't be on security
for you pledge the 100 but I mean you
couldn't do it on your signature and you
could so it's not true actually
it's not I can't I mean it's not true
yeah you got me thinking if you think
about it yeah it's practically speaking
if you go to the bank and you make
$50,000 a year and you say on my
signature my perfect credit score
I have no collateral to pledge
whatsoever I make fifty thousand bucks
will you loan me a hundred thousand
dollars let me give you the answer no
that's what they're going to tell you
okay that's exactly what they're going
to tell you bank after bank after bank
after bank but if you walk into that
same Bank and say I make 50 grand I have
a hundred thousand dollars that I can
put up as a CD as collateral to borrow a
hundred thousand dollars they go I got
zero risk here this bozo defaults I'm
cashing in the CD and covering my loan
every banker will make that loan yeah
yeah with a zero credit score yeah so
it's actually false thank you Dave
think about it y'all see that only
Instagram later okay yeah cuz I don't
know how to put it there but you will
all right insta not Dave yeah it just
bothers me save on instagrams because my
team is really good
at it and I'm not what Dave you you're
still you still have a million followers
on Instagram so YouTube's more for
messing with my follow
hey man listen I me followers it's to
point to a lot yeah I mean I think about
though see that's another thing that's
like the chaplain giving financial
advice you get Instagram financial
advice I'd be a dumb idea
you know what i'ma say they don't
Instagram it o told me this an Instagram
influencers and makes their whole living
influencing oh my god